steve sysolak announced new plans today  to support nevadans in addiction  recovery  a new state program called the recovery  friendly workplace initiative  will give employers resources they need  to help their employees  he made the announcement during  addiction recovery day at the  legislature earlier this morning  recovery friendly workplace initiative  encourages healthy and safe working  environments  where employers and employees and  communities collaborate  to create positive change eliminate  stigma  and support recovery in the workplace  and in the community  and there are several bills in the state  legislature that would provide  funding and grants for addiction  recovery programs